この動画では現在の生成AIの限界についてご説明したいと思います。
ここまで生成AIが大雑把に何をしているのか、その仕組みの長所法を見てまいりました。
一方にですね、その仕組みというものは限界を持っているわけですね。
この動画では現在の生成AIのできないこと、苦手なことを原理から理解していこうと思います。
それではやっていきましょう。
まずですね、よくあるのがこういう誤解なんですね。
生成AI自体には限界がある、あるいは信用できない、だから研究では使わない、こういうふうに思っている人も結構多いんじゃないかと思います。
一方でですね、この動画の立場としてはですね、限界を原理で知った上で、あとは倫理的な考え方を知った上でですね、
適切に研究へのAIの影響を知り、マネジメントをすることによって活用できるということをお伝えできればというふうに思っています。
使わない理由ではなく、どこを人がして、あるいはどこがAIに任せられるのかというのを考えるために、この動画を作っております。
一方ですね、AIの限界というのもかなり重たい話ではあるんですね。
その一つ目が最も有名なハルシネーションでございます。
日本では幻覚というふうにいたしますが、要するに最もらしい嘘を自信満々に出してくる現象のことです。
皆さんはですね、いかにも本当らしいことが返ってきたのに、よく見たり、事実を使ったということはないですかね。
僕結構あるんですけど、この図にあるようにですね、次のを予測するということをAIはやっているわけでございます。
その上でですね、ありそうな言葉を選んでいるわけでございます。
問題はここで、さっき言ったようにですね、AIは事実を出すというよりも、あくまで流暢性によって評価しているものだから、うまく出ないこともあり得ると。
この先にですね、事実と称号しないということをですね、必要か本当か確認するAIというのがいる場合もあります。
あるいは、AIエージェントのように何回か推論を繰り返すことによってですね、その事実じゃない場合には、他の回答を出している場合もあります。
でも、そうでもしてもですね、スルーされる場合があるんですね。
そういった場合にはですね、誤りもあくまでですね、堂々と間違えるようなことがあったりします。
本来であればですね、分からないことは分からないと言ってほしいわけですよ。そうはなってないということなんですね。
ハルシネーション、その最もらしい捏造をする上でですね、正しさを確かめる役割が最初はありない場合には、こういうことが起きますし、その役割が不十分の場合というのも全然あるということです。
あとですね、そういうことが起きる原因としてはですね、知識のカットオフなんていうのもあります。
学習した時点よりは新しいことは知らないということですね。最初の話でもそれっぽく答えてしまうわけでございます。
このようなハルシネーションというのはですね、バグではなくて次のトークンを予測するという仕組みの機械だったりします。
もちろんこれを乗り越えるために、例えば知識のカットオフを乗り越えるのであればですね、
AI自体がウェブを検索するというようなツールを読み出してですね、最新のウェブ情報を検索して戻してくる。
それによって最新の情報を、ある程度答えられるということはありますけど、
それでも本質的にはですね、この次のことを予測したり、あるいはあくまで推論を積み重ねたりと、そういうことしかしてないということなんですね。
ちょっと発展ですけども、なんでハルシネーションって入れてるようにならないんだと思います。
それはですね、訓練するときも評価するときも当てずっぽを褒めてしまうからなんですね。
で、訓練で生成AI自体は次の言葉を予測することを絶対やってるわけですけど、
審議っていうのは別に得点化してるわけじゃないんですね。
あくまでありそうだなってことに報いてるわけでございます。
最もラッシャーだけを学んでるわけです。
それから分からないってことをですね、原点する採点方法じゃなくて、
推測をした方が高得点になるように、つまりロスが減るようになってるんですね。
なので、これを皆さんの試験で例えるとですね、空欄はゼロ点になるわけですよ。
でも、勘で埋まって当てれば加点されるわけですよ。
なので、勘でも埋めるっていうふうにトレーニングされてるわけですね。
なんか共通試験を思い出しますよね。
で、同じ理由でモデルでもですね、不確実でも自信ありげに断言するような形の方でも、
とりあえず順調だったらいいわけですから、そうなっちゃう。
そしてですね、こうしたものっていうのは、評価の設計みたいなところを変えないと原理的には残るわけですね。
だから、たまに間違うというよりも、正しさを判定する仕組みがですね、
現状トレーニングの中に特に入っているわけじゃないんだよと、
そういうことを理解いただければというふうに思います。
これ、姉ちゃんに論文出てて結構面白いんですけども、
採点ルールを書くだけで知ったかぶりが減るらしいと。
つまり、もともとですね、空欄0点で、
勘だったら過点だったから推測しようと得だったんだけど、
採点を加えてですね、不正解にマイナスをつけるよ、
危険は0点だよってするとですね、
わからないっていうのはまだ安全になって、
無理な断言が減るというふうに言われています。
あるいは、自信度。
この回答の確信の度を添えて書くのもちょっと有効だと言われています。
こういうふうなですね、プロンプトを入れた上で聞くと、
それなりに回答が整うんじゃないかというふうに言われているわけですが、
しかしそれでもですね、
ハルシティン書をゼロにすることはできないということで、
AI自体がその意味ではですね、完璧ではないと。
つまり出てきた回答はかなり検証しないとまずいよってことを言っているわけでございます。
それからですね、皆さんちょっとこれはお手元でぜひ実演してください。
実在しない文章を書式まで完璧に作って言ってくる場合は結構あります。
特に無料版のAIなんていうのはそういうことがまだあったり、
すると思います。
形式が合っているのでですね、詳しくないとそれっぽいんですよね。
なので仕方なしということですけども、
一件ずつ裏取りするというのが必要なのかなと思います。
出典をですね、ご自身で確認してから使うようにしてみてください。
こちらバイアスの話、同じように出しましたが、平均を当てにいく性質という風な意味で考えるとですね、
画像でもバイアスがどんどん出てくるわけですね。
つまり、最もらしそうな像を選ぶ仕組みなので、
いわゆるですね、AI学習時に触れた典型的なデータから外れる人というのが出にくいわけですね。
例えば看護師さんのデータを写真で勉強したときに、
8割、例えば女性だった、あるいは7割女性だったとすると、
女性ばっかり出やすくなっちゃうということなんですね。
なので、最もらしさで出しているということはですね、
ある意味、多様性だったり、小数字だったり、
外れ値を取りこぼすようなこともあるので、
通したことは理解しておく必要があるのかなという風に思います。
それから、このような限界というのもあります。
一つはフレーム問題です。
人はですね、関係ないことを捨ててですね、
考える範囲を絞り込めるんですね。
例えば論文を書いている中で、僕地球の専門家なんですけど、
毎回毎回論文のために地球の時点とかって書かないわけですよ。
ただし、AIというのはそういう言葉にされるような
暗黙の前提に対してですね、弱いので、
十分なコンテキストとかフレームを与えないといけないわけですね。
同じ言葉であっても、文脈を与えないと全然違うことを意味することがあります。
自分の質問の時に、そこら辺の文脈をぶっ飛ばしてですね、
何もなしにポンって、
ただ単にプロンプト投げて聞いてしまうとですね、
そのコンテキストやフレームから外れた回答が出てきて、
なんじゃ役に立たんじゃんということになるわけでございます。
そのようなフレーム問題というのはですね、
多分解決するのはかなり難しいというふうに言われています。
現状では、例えばAIのプロンプトをどう整理するかというのの中でですね、
コンテキストエンジニアリングなども出てきてますけども、
かなり根深い問題としてここがあるわけです。
それからですね、出力されたコード、プログラミングコードなど出力することがあると思うんですけども、
動くからというと正しいわけではないんですね。
僕が結構怖いなと思ったのは、
気が悪しで立ちたときにですね、
欠損値のところをですね、全部勝手に埋めてたってことなんですね。
なんか平均ちっちゃくないかなと思ったらですね、
ゼロみたいな値が入ってて、
勝手に埋まってるじゃんみたいなことがあったわけです。
そういうふうなエラーが出なくても、
誤った数値のままですね、
削り進むようなパスを選びがちな気がしています。
なので、十分にプログラミング言語のですね、
書いたら読む必要があるのかなと思っていて、
テストや検証の部分は、
人が担保したり、あるいは他のAIからですね、
ちゃんと検証したりってことが必要なのかと思います。
あとですね、
全体最適化の壁なんてのがあったりします。
部分的には最適でも全体平均的によるってことですね。
これはですね、
このドシアンドハウザーという人たちが
サインスターバンスに2024年に出してますけども、
生成AIで小説を書くようなタスクをさせましたと。
その時にですね、
みんな生成AIに何回か聞いてもいいよというふうに
言われた状態でやってたんですけど、
その小説の面白さ、
つまり創造性はどうなったかってことなんですね。
生成AIに使ったグループというのはですね、
この創造性というのは上がったし、
しかも質、つまり中身のですね、
多分書いていく中での質というのも上がっているんだろうと思います。
一方で集団の多様性、つまり面白い作品、面白い小説って、
多分投票しもないことを思いついたり、
こんなアイデアあるんだみたいなところが来てると思うんですよ。
そういうふうな集団の多様性みたいなハズレ値みたいなのが出なくなった、
少なかったというのを言っているわけですね。
もちろんこれ統計的にそうだったというだけで、
ハズレ値なんていうのも出るんでしょうけども、
個人の創造性と集団の多様性というのは異なっているよというのは非常に下に飛んでいると思います。
研究のテーマ設定をですね、AIと一緒にするとですね、
おそらくその個人にとっては解きやすい問題にはなりやすいのかもしれません。
でもみんながそれをすると、
集団全体として面白いテーマが出にづらくなるということを言っているようにもありますよね。
こういうふうな投与設定と統合というところはですね、
かなり人の付加価値があるんじゃないかなというふうに思います。
ということでちょっとまとめとなりますが、
限界の裏返しというのはある意味、
人が今でもやらないといけないことなんですよね。
出力が検証する必要があって、
ハルシン症があったり、フェイクがあったり、
禁止バイアスがあったりするということで、
AIの出力そのものをですね、豊かに考える。
一歩立ち止まってからAIを見るというのはとても重要だと思います。
それからこの引用とか数値、こういうコードなどはですね、
位置情報で裏取ったり、そもそもそういうところをですね、
全部丸投げしてしまわないというのは重要かなと思います。
自分で裏の数値を取っておくとかですね、
裏取りする必要があるんじゃないでしょうか。
それから本物らしいということと、
本当であるというようなことはまた違うということをご説明しました。
AIというのは流暢性という意味で本物らしいものを出しているようになっています。
なのでその点はですね、十分に注意して、
例えば発信源を探ったりですね、
本当かなというふうにルールから遡って考えたりというのは、
重要かなというふうに思っています。
人間が得意なことというのを3つ言いました。
前提と範囲の設定だったり、テストと検証だったりですね、
あるいは問いと統合の部分だったりというのは、
AIに丸投げしていたら全然できないよということを言いました。
人間の得意地みたいなところというのをどう出すかというのがあると思います。
生成AIに最適化されるだけで全然面白くないですからね。
ということで、AIは正しさも文学も内蔵していないので、
人間はあくまでそこを理解した上でですね、
AIに対して聞いていく必要なのかなと思います。
限界を知るというのはですね、AIは使えないと言っているわけではないんですよ。
AIは怖い道具から使える道具に変わる方法を学んでいるわけでございます。
なので、AIの限界というのにアンテナを立ててですね、
いろいろと勉強していただくと面白いのかなというふうに思う次第です。
ということで、この動画のご視聴ありがとうございました。